Black Panther is upon us and we're with
the Stars at the Regal Hollywood
premiere Plus Adele dressed up like
Dolly Parton and it's our new favorite
thing and Gigi and Bella Hadid stripped
down for British Vogue everybody we made
it through the Grammys if you watched my
live recap thank you and guess what the
Oscars aren't for another month so we're
off the hook which is perfect because we
have some things we need to talk about
starting with Marvel's Black Panther
this movie has got people hyped
including me
it hits theaters February 16th and last
night the purple carpet was rolled out
for the regal world premiere Marvel's
invitation said the dress code for the
premiere was royal a salute to the royal
nation of Wakanda in the movie and let
me tell you the stars look like royalty
including Lupita Nyong'o she slays every
red carpet but really showed up and
turned out in this deep purple custom
Versace damn that's good are you guys I
don't have to tell you this but black
panther is the hottest ticket in town it
set a record for presale tickets and
even Lupita couldn't get any by the way
did you ever get those tickets you were
trying to get no I didn't I didn't it
was sold out I haven't seen the film
before so for me I'm just genuinely
excited like I wanted to come in just as
a fan just one to watch a movie Michael
B Jordan brought out his entire family
and friends but no date because he told
us he's technically single ladies by
Michael plays Marvel's next great bad
guy Erik kill monger which could very
well be up there on the list of the
greatest movie villains with Heath
Ledger's Joker said you drew from like
Heath Ledger's inspiration when he was
the Joker should go to the place for her
kill manga right yeah in a sense of like
you know you know you want as an actor
you know you why certain performances
them that motivates you inspire and for
me you know Heath performance as a
villain was so captivating I couldn't
stop watching and I was like man okay
if I can get into that rear air you know
of um of just a character where people
empathize but still kind of understand
but still are a little taken back by it
that I would you know it'll work out
early buzz around black panther is
saying this movie is a defining moment
in cinema and the black panther himself
chadwick boseman told us it's an
experience he had never seen before
hopefully doesn't take me all year to
actually get a ticket all right we have
work from the epic world premiere on our
site ET online.com and tonight on ET but
switching gears now to a different kind
of royalty Gigi and Bella Hadid are
bringing the heat and their first duel
covers the sisters smolder and gold
Versace on the March issue of British
Vogue but inside the mag the supermodel
sister act posed completely negative
we also dished on growing up as siblings
in the spotlight and let's just say
don't ever come for them 22 year old
Gigi admits she's a protective older
sister telling the mad quote she's one
of the only people i'll get aggressive
for embellish shared the same sentiment
adding she makes me so proud I would do
anything for her alright moving on now I
like many of you felt
Adele's absence from the Grammys this
year I feel like in between records
Adele abandons us and I'm like never
mind I'll find someone like you but on
Tuesday she popped back on our feeds
channeling her inner Dolly Parton Adele
tweeted this photo dressed as the
country music icon the hair check
cleavage baring pantsuit check she also
shared this sweet message in honor of
Dolly riding the effortless Queen of
song Dolly Parton you love you and we
wish we could possess an ounce of your
ability quoting Dolly's most famous song
Adele also added I'll always love you
and the feeling is mutual because Dolly
wrote right back and I will always love
you now this isn't the first time Adele
has bowed down to one of her queens as
of late just last week Celine Dion
shared this photo with Adele who came to
see Celine performed in Vegas rocking a
Celine Dion Titanic T no less because
Adele is clearly a fangirl just like us
who knows if she's working on that next
great album but she is clearly living
her life
so go out and live yours too but make
sure you're subscribed to our channel
because I've got some really fun
interviews lined up for you guys this
week so comeback like comment and share
I love you goodbye
[Music]